peu
[Musique]
petite plaisance c'est le nom de la
modeste et jolie maison blanche
qu'habite marguerite yourcenar dans
l'île de monde et vert situé dans l'état
du maine nord-est des etats-unis la
nature y est superbe
il ya des écureuils et bien que toutes
les maisons soit en bois les pins les
chaînes et les érables sont les amis des
hommes derrière le cadreur à quelques
pas le sait en atlantique et devant lui
né il ya soixante seize ans d'un père
français et d'une mère belge installé
ici depuis 30 ans marguerite yourcenar
marguerite yourcenar qui se veut la
servante des oiseaux marguerite
yourcenar
l'auteur de livres considérait déjà
comme des classiques de notre
littérature mémoires d'hadrien l'oeuvre
au noir souvenirs pieux archives d'une
heure et cetera
loin de paris elle s'est hissée au
premier rang des auteurs de langue
française à la seule force de son
poignet d'écrivain nous sommes à la mi
septembre déjà l'humidité des pelouses
et les sous-bois gagne sur le soleil
bientôt comme dans toute la nouvelle
angleterre
il va faire très froid et lorsque ces
images passons sur vos pauses de
télévision marguerite yourcenar la
réserve degois fête sera rentrée la
petite plaisance
cerné par la neige entouré de livres
greg chinois anglais japonais
elle va laisser courir sur le papier sa
culture son intelligence sa sensibilité
est ce qui fait qu'elle est une grande
artiste
la musique de seymour je veux savoir
marie dur sonar depuis quand sur votre
passeport à la rubrique profession ya
marqué écrivain bien en réfléchissant je
me rends compte que c'est depuis 1920
c'était il y avait 25 ans et c'est la
première fois je crois roger précepteur
appellation officielle mais vous aviez
déjà publié un livre et j'avais déjà
publié un livre j'appelle et je portais
déjà le reste et rudiments le nom de
mario veille au sénat et à paris
vous avez mais qui est devenu légal
entre temps mais ce qu'on décide de
devenir écrivain comme blue décide de
devenir pâtissière ou kinésithérapeute
je trouve pas immédiatement la réponse
parce que évidemment j'ai dû
probablement toujours pensée va à nantes
vous il faisait quelque chose j'écrirai
si j'avais vécu dans une famille
différente c'est dans cette époque des
musées mais aucun talent pour la musique
du reste ou de peinture ou de quoi que
ce soit et il est possible que je me
serais tourner vers une autre profession
je crois pas
les quelque chose de sacré à être
particulièrement écrit ben je pose cette
question parce que dans votre premier
livre
alexis alexis un moment dit ceci il dit
il dit il manifeste sa volonté de venir
un grand musicien alors musiciens un
grand étant bien sûr et il dit à maman
enfant j'ai désiré la gloire est-ce que
vos enfants vous avez un enfant j'ai
désiré d'abord en effet et la gloire de
l'écrivain je savais pas trop où je
voulais quelque chose d'important
qu'est ce que voulait dire par
l'important je ne sais pas avec une
chose qui intéresse les gens à qui leur
parlait faire une impression c'est vrai
bien plus je vais même l'impression que
c'était d'arriver que ça se passerait je
sais pas trop pourquoi vous en aviez
secrètement le circuit du mans
d'impression alexys ou là le traité du
vin combat il paraît donc en 1929 c'est
ça en 1929 et vous l'avez écrire 28
c'était un sujet à redire pour les pubs
pour l'époque où elle que vous avez donc
arrivé avec quelques exemples mais pas
très nombreux enfin est-ce qu'on est
encore nous en quelques phrases pourriez
dire qu'un sujet aujourd'hui d'alexis
oui il suffit d'alexis est l'histoire
d'un jeune homme très doué mais assez
fragile
de santé et enfin surtout de résistance
est à la nuit ou en difficulté lui
présente la vie qui est homosexuel pour
employer ce mot puisqu'elle n'en trouve
pas de notre monde un moment que vous
n'employez pas à vous que je n'emploie
pas jamais non jamais mais parce que je
n'aime pas les étiquettes mais qui enfin
se marie aussi des sentiments religieux
assez profonds se marie avec une jeune
femme tout à fait remarquable et se rend
compte que les choses ne vont pas très
bien il ya un enfant etc
mais leur vie n'est pas très heureuse et
que cette mélancolie ces difficultés
contribué à miner sa carrière de
musicien
ce qui fait qu'il se décide à quitter sa
femme pour lequel ils avaient leur mot
qu'audrey ce fait même de tendresse et
il lui écrit pour nous expliquer la
situation et lui dire à une remarque il
s'agit d'ailleurs d'un homme très jeune
il a 24 ans et je me suis souvent dit si
j'avais écrit une suite d'alexis sa
position pour penser qu'il n'est pas
très chaud à 80 ans nous ne
retrouverions pas avec sa femme
et puis de nouveau à 40 ans divorcée la
vie beaucoup plus souple qu'on imagine à
24 ans mais la suite logique peut-être
d'alexis ça a été la réponse de sa femme
monique moi je crois qu'elle appartenait
aux tic qui ne répondait pas
d'ailleurs elle n'a pas répondu elle
n'apparaît pas mais ce qui est ce qu'il
faut souligner dans ce lille qui est
superbe c'est son extraordinaire pudeur
mais remarquez que la pudeur tient dans
partir d'abord à ce que je souhaitais
que la pudeur ce il trouva ensuite à ce
que le bien que je pense à ce naturel
ment à des quêtes personnage a des
situation que je connaissais autour de
moi néanmoins le décor était placée dans
la vieille autriche au moins une dizaine
d'années une vingtaine d'années avant
que l'époque où le livre a été publié
donc c'était encore le monde ainsi ce
sobre et subtile et raffinée
d'avant-guerre d'avant la première
guerre qu'il fallait respecter cette
voie ce style c'est même c'est manière
courtoise souvent dit qu alexis est un
portrait d'une fois ce qui est tout à
fait fascinant dans ce livre c'est
l'extraordinaire économie du style il
n'y a pas un gramme de chair en trop
chaque mot est à sa place et quand on
pense que vous avez écrit ce livre 24
ans alors qu'à cet âge là au contraire
on a tendance à en remettre trop en
rajouter
c'est tout à fait étonnant je vais la
lire un petit passage vous m'aimiez je
ne suis pas assez vain pour croire que
vous m'aimiez d'amour
je me demande encore comment vous avez
pu je ne dis pas vous et prendre deux
mois mais m'adopter ainsi chacun de nous
sait peu de choses sur l'amour que
l'entente que d autres l'amour pour vous
n'était peut-être une bonté passionnés
ou bien je vous ai plus je vous ai plus
justement par ses qualités qui croise
trop souvent à l'ombre de nos défauts
les plus graves
la faiblesse l'indécision la subtilité
surtout vous m'avez plein j'avais été
assez imprudents pour vous inspirer
pitié parce que vous aviez été bonne
pendant quelques semaines vous avez
trouvé naturel de là
toute la vie vous avez cru qu'il
suffisait d'être parfaite pour être
heureuse
j'ai cru suffisant pour être heureux de
n'être plus coupable c'est superbe
je dirais que c'est une écriture
quasiment janséniste est à 24 ans oui on
est quelques fois on s'est dit ça va de
4 ans vous avez maintenant maintenant à
mémoire d'adrien qui va vous assurez la
renommée c'est un mec qui paraît en 1951
mais c'est un avocat vous travaillez en
tout cas auquel vous songé depuis bien
longtemps j'avais commencé à 19
j'avais même écrit une lire sous une
forme dieng à la gobineau complète
ça m'a paru impossible pour une lan pour
une autre fois qu'il y avait des
passages qui n'était pas si mal que ça
je lève tôt j'essayais sous sa forme
d'un essai et voulait abandonner parce
que se demander une évolution même très
très développée sur un point sur
quelques points que je n'avais pas bon
pourquoi avez vous choisi ce personnage
de vriendt compte 1 19 ans et je m'étais
mis en tête d'écrire quelque chose sur
adrien évidemment bien entendu vous
l'avez été la jeune touriste qui se
promène dans la ville adriana de
l'époque beaucoup plus belle à l'époque
aujourd'hui votre n'y avait pas mis des
parkings des buvettes et quelques
statues jardin qu'elle n'arrive
peut-être pas les palaces ses parades ou
moins de près l'endroit où on les a
mises mais je voyais donc ce que
j'imaginais c'était leur prêt relais
mixte le premier rang profond qui a été
profondément un amateur de la pensée et
de la vie grecs qui se nommer lui-même
fils élève et l'on est à celle évoquée
sa retraite son petit rôle dans la ville
adriana en y repensant ça m'a paru vague
j'ai essayé de d'évoquer toute sa vie au
moins une partie de sa vie et là je
manque évidemment
l'augmentation nécessaire la grandeur
d'adrien il ya plusieurs espèces de
manière de la considérer d'abord c'est
presque un enfant pacifique
on peut on peut dire qu adrien était
pacifiste il a rendu certaines conquête
pour terminer immédiatement des guerres
et pendant ces vingt années de règne il
n'y a eu qu'une seule guerre a été
transmis une espèce de rébellion de
guérilla qui n'a pas pu éviter la guerre
de palestine qui d'ailleurs la plus ou
moins tu es et pendant les cinquante ans
qui ont suivi
grâce aux arrangements qu'il avait pris
la paix romaine a continué à régner
enfin avec quelques petits accrocs par
ci par là
donc en 1948 c'était un personnage
passionnant qu'un homme qui disait lui
même qu'il avait remis deux qui la verse
stabiliser le monde c'est la première
premier élément grandeur le second ckd
rien n'est pas du tout le romain typique
le romanesque on les voit dans l'est
dans la guerre civile de montherlant
paris l'enquêté du port des yachts
ce n'est pas un homme qui a été élevé à
rome c'est un romain de province
une famille de venue des bords de
l'adriatique et installé en espagne
depuis des générations
il y avait il en lui du sang cents du
100 ibère se seront ne sais pas c'est
possible mais en tout cas il y a les
aspects de lui ils sont très différents
celui du roman habituel il a sa sobriété
il ya sa passion de la chasse que je
suis loin de partager mais qui fait déjà
de lui le poids nécessaire d'un rêve
pour preuve il ya sa passion du deuil
cette espèce de frénésie sombre c'est
tombé dans la fantaisie et dans le roman
est dans le dans la poésie plus ou moins
imaginaire d'une pensée ou vêtements
noirs de l'espagne xvième siècle mais
tout de même le seul homme qui ait pris
deuil pour une impératrice côté de ma
mère la femme ne sont pas nécessaires
le seul homme qui a élevé le grand
tombeau à des morts du passé et aller
aussi à des morts de son temps et le
slam qui est invaincue
le tu as presque insensé pour un ami
mort pendant neuf ans elle se préoccuper
de multiplier ses portraits au point que
nous avons donc à personne d'autre de
l'antiquité autant de portraits que
d'anti n'ose donc il a été un grand
prince il n'a pas extraordinaire montre
individuel n'empêche pas les gens se
marrent que adrien termine sa vie sur un
échec et quel échec sur ce parce que la
révolte de la palestine qui va l'écraser
dans le sens il a rasé jérusalem a bien
sûr bien sûr et c'est ce que trompeuse
jour on remarquait il n'y a eu un énorme
une énorme correspondant aux le mot
américain phénomène produit c'est bien
ce genre de correspondance par exemple
causée par la publication d'adrian en
français et puis ensuite en anglais et
la plupart des gens je m'en suis aperçu
voyez adrien comme une réussite aurait
bien entendu adrien tante qui a réussi
mais pas du tout dans les conditions
éclatante qu'on imagine tout d'abord
c'est un homme qui a pour arriver au
pouvoir a mis 40 ans en passant par
toutes les tous les stages de la
discipline militaire et civil et
quelques compromis et probablement même
quelques impostures passé pour obtenir
le prêt relais keshi pâle ensuite
s'agissait qu'il fut aussi sincère que
quelqu'un peut l'aise qui ne peut-être
pas beaucoup dire ensuite une fois
arrivé au pouvoir il ay à ce moment de
d'activité est perdu et enfin joyeuse
lorsqu'il s'aperçoit qu'il peut établir
la paix rétablie en situation économique
du monde et très vite on fasse à l'eni
vraiment la rencontre avec cantine aux
roses qui produit représente son idéal
humain très vite produit cette espèce
d'enivrement les choses vont trop bien
elles vont même si bien qu'elles vont
mal et les font vraiment ce produit au
suicide d'entre eux
c'est le second d'effondrement grille en
avait eu un premier durant la guerre
partant qu'il avait cru qui
n'arriveraient pas à l' empire et
ensuite il se remet bien sûr il
redevient en preuve très efficient qui
l'étaient déjà
mais il n'y a un troisième
effondrement la guerre de palestine avec
la naïveté qu'on presque toutes les
nations riches et puissantes est supposé
au sommet de la civilisation de leur
temps il s'est dit persuadé qu'il
n'avait qu'à paraître en palestine pour
persuader les israélites que il
accepterait ces civilisations romaine et
ne l'ont pas acceptée du moins une
grande partie n'a pas accepté et il se
trouvait en fait une épouvantable guerre
civile qui a duré trois ans donc pour un
emprunt pacifiste c'est un choc
mais d'une certaine manière avec cette
guerre la palestine est compris
d'hôtellerie qui participent au tragique
de notre temps nous avons absolument et
c'est à ce moment là d'ailleurs que je
les montre et réfléchissant à l'avenir
en se disant que tout ça c'est très bien
que rome en étant encore à sa belle
époque mais que cette belle époque ne
peut pas d'innover mais vous dit quelque
part je sais plus où que vous connaissez
mieux
adrien que votre père observant parce
que tout de même nous avons pas mal de
document assure adrien il est vrai
qu'ils sont fragmentaires et il est vrai
que beaucoup émane de chroniqueurs mais
york qui ne comprenaient pas au vaincu
qui s'exhale gérait les choses qui les
voyaient d'une façon rudimentaire et
naïve comme des journalistes pas très
informé mais en fait tout de même les
documents pas s'y tromper enlever un
certain nombre de documents jettent pas
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
j'ai aussi des périodes sombres tandis
que la période les périodes ombre pour
moi sont très importants dans un
personnage
il ya pour adrien une période de
pénombre
lorsqu'il les jeunes officiers lorsqu'il
fait la guerre lorsqu'il accepte qu'il
veut bien lui bien obligé de le faire
la politique ne sont pas nécessaires
mais nous savons pas grand chose s'était
porté lui même en quelque sorte la
presque l'oublier
une fois arrivé au pouvoir mais c'est
tout de même une période dans lequel
nous ne voyons pas dans des tailles
c'est quand même curieux vous puissiez
dire que vous connaissez mieux un
empereur du deuxième siècle après
jésus-christ que notre père avait vécu
pendant vingt cinq scellés
illusion et gens qui pensent toujours
que la famille est quelque chose dont on
est excessivement proche
voyons un peu les choses de près un père
est un monsieur qui vous a eu comme cris
dans mon cas quand il avait 45 ans mais
tant que j'ai commencé à observer quand
j'en avais moi cette il en avait donc 52
donc toute sa jeunesse était derrière
lui j'ai dû reconstituer sa jeunesse par
ces récits qui heureusement était assez
abondant des mulets poser des questions
il y a répondu un peu plus tard cavale
de sept ans évidemment et ensuite il
n'ya le fait que le fait même d'être une
fille fausses ou à fils foncez c'est la
situation d'hier d'un personnage et mon
père et on pense pas assez que ce père
est un monsieur bien servi à lui cette
aventure à lui ses soucis à lui et qui
peut être un très bon père mais que le
fait de la paternité ne leur ne le
composent pas entièrement
il ya d'autres éléments qu'on risque
d'oublier mais on ne doit pas vivre
impunément je me suis j'ose dire avec un
personnage comme adrien pendant vingt
ans sans que je sais pas il vous modifie
peut-être un terrier nos personnages ne
modifie tous nous apprenons c'est ce qui
ad'ailleurs de six faux lorsqu'on
s'imagine que un personnage chez nous si
c'était nous ils sont ils seraient aussi
pauvre que nous c'est à dire il l'aurait
nous mêmes limites
l'important est d'avoir un personnel qui
nous a pas quelque chose dont
tempérament dans la vie soit assez
différente pour que nous nous ayons
quelque sorte des rallonges n'ont quà
adrien vous a modifié la fréquentation
de probablement son intelligence et
d'étirements très intelligent est ce que
vous diriez que me adrien ma vie mais
move est moins que l'histoire allait
jouer de nouveau vous citer des exemples
littéraires parce que ce sont en quelque
sorte des répondants vous rappelez vous
la françoise de proust qui était si
impitoyable pour l'un fille de cuisine
mais quand elle lit dans vingt livres de
laisser la description de la maladie de
la fille de cuisine du bailleur
c'est une grossesse tout d'un coup se
met à pleurer à la peau parce que dans
la vie courante afin nous nos défenses
je suppose mais le fait même nous devons
continuer à vivre et qui pourrait tout
de même que la vie pratique continue
nous avons fait de sentir le trafic des
événements sauf par moments cen-sad
nous serions tous à plat par terre
adrien dit ceci et ses magnifiques la
plus haute forme de vertu
la seule que je supporte encore la ferme
détermination d'être utile pour moi ç'a
toujours été une idée maîtresse et ça
explique peut-être les 40 adhésion à 46
voilà c'est pour ça que placé dans un
linceul coup je dis ça y est et c'est
aussi zénon peine jusqu'au dernier
moment on veut nous viendrons à lebron
le bilan de ce qui compose énoncés de
respect dit il modestement du tlm
mariton snav dans un livre noir qui
t'arrive plus récents puisqu'ils datent
de 1968 et je dirais que c'est un il me
sens à notre cas que c'est un roman plus
à lille ou plutôt les plus romanesques
que rien ne serait ce parce que le
personnage zénon a été inventé oui et
puis aussi surtout parce que le
personnage et non comme la plupart de
nous passent par des circonstances
excessivement variés adrien a eu a eu
certainement beaucoup de désagréments
quelques graves malheurs dans sa vie
mais enfin s'il est tout de même
l'empereur est tout de même un homme qui
comme il le dit lui même n'a jamais
connu la faim et jusqu'à un certain
point choisi sa destinée et non et pour
zénon est en fuite est trop car du temps
et non s'arrange comme il peut se
faufile à travers les difficultés les
drames et y les préjugés de son temps et
il est pour ainsi dire d'abord vaincu
sont envolés le xvième siècle 16e saint
caprais aussi bien peine d'ailleurs à
yani rapports entre les deux personnages
tous deux sont avant tout à celle du
genre tous deux dans cette passion de
servir et tous deux ont une certaine
ouverture métaphysique plus grande g et
non parce que tout mais maintenant ça ne
peut pas se permettre de passer son
temps à contempler vous dire que c'est
non et philosophe médecin un chimiste
mais leurs tempéraments sont très
différents adrien est un homme
évidemment violemment des motifs c'est
non et on contraire on a l'impression
d'un tempérament presque indestructible
ci ne tuez pas 50 59 ans on a
l'impression qu'il est encore 25 ans
devant lui tu es un homme fiable qui
s'est en quelque sorte durci a
l'expérience de la vie mais ce qui pour
moi ne rend passionnant c'est pourquoi
j'ai dit que j'aimais et non comme un
frère c'est à quel point ce qu'il vit se
rapproche de ce que nous vivons en coin
d'abord une vie dans une europe coupée
par un rideau de fer ce n'est pas le
rideau de fer communiste capitalise de
notre époque c'est le rideau de fer
catholiques protestants ce qui au fond
exactement la même chose dans les deux
cas il s'agit d'un terrain politique
d'intérêt foncier pas que dans contre
lesquelles il ne peut pas lutter c'est
un homme qui se trouve pris entre des
vues police religieuse métaphysique
scientifiques différentes on voit ces
différentes théories ces différents
systèmes du monde granby avait au
contraire se faner comme nous le voyons
nos jours une théorie prend la place
d'une autre et où tout est encore ouvert
jusqu'à certains pourraient et enfin
c'est un homme qui fait face à un monde
de plus en plus assombri
jusqu'au jour où il n'y a plus qu'à
sortir et pour pour ne pas s'imposer le
pire le pire dans des conditions dignité
et surtout ne pas imposer des compromis
ce qui est vrai c'est que vous donnez
dans mémoires d'hadrien une
vision du monde à mon avis plus j'ai pas
que le terme employé dire plus
optimistes plus d'oreilles mais le doré
doré que dans un souk et noir est-ce que
ça correspond à une étape de votre
propre révolution je crois que ça
correspond à la fois à l'histoire et à
une étape de mon évolution
d'une part le monde hanté du fait même
que c'est le monde hanté et mou et moins
et plus jeune que le monde 2 et non de
ces siècles
il a par conséquent vu un peu moins
d'horreur et un peu moins de projets dit
il y a encore lâché abrial impossibilité
de croire qu'un grand esprit peut
pendant non seulement quelques années la
paix mais pendant un temps assez long
stabiliser le monde du temps et non
simple plaisanterie n'est plus question
de faire et d'une autre j'ai bien peur
que il reçoit exactement comme du temps
et nos et d'autre part adrien a été
écrit en 48 et dieu sait que les
événements en 48 étaient telles que nous
donnait déjà on peut noter que déjà
donné dans le pessimisme absolu mais
enfin comme toujours après une guerre
terminée il ya ce moment de relèvement
dans lequel on se dit enfin là la raison
la sagesse ou tout au moins désaccord
mettons raisonnable vont peut-être
triomphe et montbray de s'imposer tandis
que dans l'oeuvre au noir écrites entre
60 et 65
on voyait déjà craqué beaucoup plus de
choses je me souviens d'un mot de robert
kanter c'est quand il avait rendu compte
de votre livre mari disait que à peu
près ceci zen adrien vit à une époque où
l'homme
avait du mal à devenir dieu alors que
c'est une envie une époque où l'homme a
du mal à devenir homme c'est absolument
vrai c'est merveilleusement dit souvent
des choses que virebayre 31 100es lors
des des phrases moi je sais que je
prends dans dans le vent noir
un de ceux-ci que disais non je me suis
gardé de faire de la vérité une idole
préférant lui laisser son nom plus
humbles d'exactitude
c'est une phrase qui m'importe beaucoup
oui sûrement parce que comme dont parle
vérité très souvent on parle de théories
comprend pour la vérité ou de dogme
comprendre la vérité dans les cantons
par l'exactitude c'est sérieux petit
aperçu du style on va voir par
comparaison combien le votre style a
évolué et combien même dans une oeuvre
pessimistes comme de celle ci combien le
style peut être coloré et riche la
viande le sang les entrailles tous cas
palpiter ai vécu lui répugnait à cette
époque de son existence car la bête
meure la douleur comme l'homme et il lui
déplaisait de digérer des agonies depuis
l'époque où il avait été égorgé lui même
un port chez un boucher de montpellier
pour vérifier s'il y avait tout dans
coïncidence entre la pulsation de
l'artère et la systole du coeur il avait
cessé de trouver utile d'employés de
termes différents pour désigner la bête
qu'on n'a pas et l'homme qu'on tue
l'animal qui crèvent et l'homme qui
meurent ses préférences en matière
d'aliments avait au pain à la bière eau
bouillie qui garde quelque chose de la
saveur épaisse de la terre aux aqueuse
verdure aux fruits rafraîchissant eaux
souterraines et sa petite racine c'est
qu'au fond aux énormes beaucoup la nuit
il est ravi et même parce que les gens
on en fait oui mais les mots glanés feu
ce livre qui s'intitule tout simplement
et joliment feu d'un livre très peu
connu
même de vos lecteurs et c'est pourtant
le lit vous certainement vous vous êtes
le plus confié au fond c'était à lui de
poèmes sont des poèmes en prose mais
sont tout de même des poèmes et en
général l école ne se pratique pas sur
des poèmes
oui mais je crois que c'est pas tout à
fait vrai que sur les poèmes
parce que d'abord il ya des récits même
manière ici même selon elle tente résume
un téléthon grâce on attend la
seigneurie et c'est parfois un lit de
moraliste aussi à l'elysée on tâche de
tirer une conséquence quel camp ou d'une
expérience vécue note ce journal d'une
passion oui mais évoqué à travers un
tout neuf tout un groupe de personnages
variés havas qui parle dont on parle ce
matin
enfin là on entend marquer cure sonar
qui parle à la première personne qui
riait les pensées et ça c'est entre les
entre les récits wiki ce blain qui gémit
des voix qui est alors vivement
vous vous dites par exemple l'amour est
un châtiment
nous sommes punis de n'avoir pas pu
rester seul je ne l'entends parfois n'y
a pas d'aidés phrase excessive dans ce
livre
et ça me rappelle un peu la fin a
également exercé de pascal qui disait
que l'homme est plus d'avoir facturé
dans une chambre s'asseoir sarralbe
évidemment dès qu'on met le nez dehors
hors de sa chambre où dès qu'on
s'attache à quelqu'un d'autre encore
certains risques et ceci par exemple un
coeur c'est peut-être malpropre c'est de
l'ordre de la table d'anatomie de l'étal
du boucher je préfère encore et j'étais
très surpris en dire ça sous votre plume
est donc là je crois que je réagis
contre la tendance france est allé
m'excuser monde au sentimentalisme
amoureux et souvent l'impression que la
france depuis moyenne alors que depuis
chrétien de troyes et en passant de la
princesse de clèves est un continent
avec les romantiques l'histoire de
duchesse de langeais ou de chèques que
serré jusqu'à nos jours a fait tellement
un plat si j'ose dire de l'amour qu'on a
beaucoup trop parlé liqueurs et pas
assez le corps d'un du corps peut-être
n'était pas grand chose à dire du
continent qu'il existe mais rien n'est
mieux que l'existant dit clair mais très
souvent ce choeur était si artificielle
venez tellement l'impression d'avoir été
en hongrie banner de l'été raté que je
me méfie toujours beau cette passion
pour raconter ce une passion très
douloureuse elle le sent tout ce temps
je n'hésiterai pas des patients non il
ya parfois des patients heureuse
enfin bon alors poids la tension atteint
alors à la fin vous dit
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous avez
vous dit qui lutte était fade d'être
heureux et pourtant vous êtes plein tout
au long du livre et jean-claude
impatience qu'on peut dire est logé
rapprocher sa du nom d'une phrase d'une
infection d'alexis donc qui avait été
écrit et fera ce qu'elle est écrite je
sais pas quinze ans avant une dizaine
d'adhésions et ali baba alexis dit ceci
il est difficile de ne pas se croire
supérieur lorsqu'on souffre davantage
mais je crois que la plupart des gens
responsables et je n'ai peut-être pas
tout à fait une illusion car enfin ils
ont appris certaines choses et vous
ajoutez enfin ici ajoute et la vue des
gens heureux donne la nausée du bonheur
ce serait un échange ne sent pas bien
évidemment quand les gens y sont très
bien on est heureux pour eux mais quand
ils sont assez déplaisant oui c'est pas
toujours joli spectacle
on va parler un petit peu marre et du
renard de deux livres les plus récents
c'est-à-dire souvenirs pieux et archives
du nord est
et je veux savoir pourquoi après vous
êtes intéressé adrien et non alexis tant
d'autres vous avez décidé de choisir vos
personnages dans votre famille je pense
que j'ai été un peu influencé par
l'oeuvre au noir
parce que pour le grenouillage m'étais
dit tâchons d'avoir des documents
nouveaux est automatique et d'entrée
souvent j'avais pris les noms de famille
particulièrement ou des noms de domaine
qui provenait documents familiaux
est-ce que vous avez choisi de parler de
vos ancêtres parce que vous vous ni
figurer à peine après dans ces deux
livres
je crois que vous êtes âgés tout au plus
de six mois six semaines mais aussi six
semaines
mais est ce que vous avez décidé de
décrire ces données parce que ce sont
vos ancêtres ou parce que vos ancêtres
sont des représentants de ce qu'on peut
appeler la condition humaine
la connexion email seulement il se
trouve nature en vue tout le monde a des
ancêtres et ils sont tous représentants
de la condition humaine se bat on n'a
pas toujours les documents dans ces
cas-ci on en avait vraiment pas mal avec
bien entendu les causes habituelles mais
tout de même ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que vous qui n'avez pas d'enfants qui
n'est pas de pause est mérité
vous avez une certaine manière
donnez une seconde naissance à ceux qui
nous ont précédés pour ressusciter les
morts comme disait giorgio merola grands
noms je crois pas non moi je prends pas
que vous ayez ressusciter les morts je
crois que vous les avez fait naître une
deuxième fois ce qui est tout à fait
différent je dois donner un exemple de
votre style on a donné d'abord le style
un peu janséniste mexique après ce style
déjà très très coloré c'était le renoir
et puis là je trouve que dans ces
notamment de rachid d'une heure je
trouve que là vous on n'est pas loin de
bruegel d'ailleurs le 19e siècle oui
mais ce qui est vous voyez un codeur ski
que dans votre cas c'est que vous avez
commencé donc par un style très très
maîtrisée dre très très économique
et puis plus vous vieillissez plus au
contraire vous allez vers un style riche
dans le sézannais annoncé sana n'ai pas
dit ça je me lasse pas les nommer mais
sait on le désire enfin de faire rentrer
juste possible de toutes les réalités
elle ce n'est pas pris plus de plaisir à
écrire justement des ouvrages que
marchive d'une heure que des ouvrages
justement plus maîtrisée comme feu comme
pas du tout les deux cages musée n'est
pas que j'ai détruit dans un grand dans
un grand état de mounir l exaltation et
idiot excitement une excitation pardon
d'un voisin américain alors quoi enfin
mettons de satisfaction à l'herbe est
alors qu'est-ce que je les vois je l'aï
retrouvé le moment je lis ce passage le
plénitude si vous voulez plénitude et
fable euros je voudrais savoir si dans
son jeune temps elle était fille
d'auberge où serpentent au château si
elle aime son homme ou le fait cocu si
elle met des cierges et l'église ou
peste contre le curé ou les deux à la
fois ci elle soigne les oiseaux malades
ou claque la porte au nez des mendiants
c'est par les faits et gestes les plus
banals qu'il faut d'abord tenté de
cerner à naître comme si on le crée
lyonnais à grands traits mais il serait
grossier de dénier à cet inconnu ses
émotions plus subtile presque plus pur
qui semble n'être du raffinement de
l'âme au sens où on suppose qu un
alchimiste raffineurs françoise a pu
aimer autant que moi la musique des
ménétriers des joueurs deviennent airs
populaires devenu aujourd'hui régal de
délicats trouvé bon un coucher de soleil
rouge sur la neige
ramassez tristement un oiselet tombé du
nid en se disant que ces grands pitié ce
qu'elle a pensé sentir l'égard de ces
contentement et de ses peines de ses
maux physiques de la vieillesse de la
mort qui vient de ceux qu'elle a aimé
qu'ils sont partis un porte ni plus ni
moins que ce que j'ai pensé senti moi
même sa vie a sans doute était plus dure
que la mienne je pourtant idée que c'est
couci couça elle est comme nous tous
dans l'inextricable et l'inéluctable et
bien moi je dis qu'à 25 ans vous
n'auriez jamais employé couci couça mais
bien sûr ce matin je ne parlais pas de
françoise bureau probablement de
françoise leur aurait dit couci couça
vous voyez c'est là où le le la
différence qu'on fait entre l'afld l'est
où les livres sont maudits
et les livres m'ont dit elle ou louis
est au fond assez absurde parce que
quand on dit et nous lui en otage d'un
doublement de parler comme si c'était
elle ou lui qui permet c'est à la
troisième personne mais c'est une
première personne déguisée
ici c'est prendre un nom qui parle alors
comment écrivez vous recevoir un passage
comme ça est ce que vous le travail est
beaucoup et ce qu'ils doublent
naturellement tout naturel tout
naturellement il ya des moments où ça ne
marche pas alors on colle et on refuse
10 fois la même paquet
il y à la creuse quelque part on
s'aperçoit pas finalement ça vient alors
souvenirs pieux premier volume c'est la
famille maternelle chute d'une heure et
la famille paternelle
on annonce un troisième volume il est
écrit et n'est pas décrit n'est même pas
encore commencé parce que ces lits
oriente eu un certain succès mais je
n'ai pas voulu faire d'espèces
d'écriture automatique et me lancer dans
la même voie que les deux précédents
j'ai voulu réfléchir dans tout les
problèmes sont tout nouveaux dans le
premier volume est le deuxième volume je
ne suis pas présentables présente comme
un enfant de six semaines dans le
suivant il faudra suivre jusqu'à sa fin
quand ce ne serait pas très raisonnable
ni très poli très courtois de l'aviron
en route
michel mon père et par conséquent nous
aurons l'histoire d'un homme qui
viennent soit pas essentiellement le
fait d'avoir vieilli qu'il soit
intéressant en plus de sa passion pour
la vie jusqu'à la fin et d'autre part il
ya milliards
il y aura forcément moi vu que j'étais
là faut bien tout est ok et alors il y
aura sept enfants qu'il faudra essayer
de décrire différents états de l'enfance
et il faut y aura les réflexions sur
l'enfant c'est là c'est plus difficile
ça me paraît difficile c'est plus
difficile d'écrire sur vous on écrire
sur rose et non sur adrien au bout on a
peur de se tromper il ya toujours la
vanité qui intervient dix ne pourrait y
avoir la timidité et pourrait avoir le
faire parce qu'on ne se voit pas
quelques grands patrons ont fait leur
porterait au miroir admirablement
rembrandt a fait toute sa vie mais en
général c'est une chose mais c'est
difficile à faire et ses dangereuses
mais vous pensez qu'on attend
patient cet ouvrage vous ça les gêne un
peu parce que j'ai l'impression il vous
est aussi éloigné la plupart les
opinions ancien de l'enfance marguerite
yourcenar pour mishima ou la vision du
vide paru chez gallimard il ya quelques
jours et jean d'ormesson pour dieu sa
vie son oeuvre paru également chez
gallimard
alors je le vidame en aurait parlé de
dieu d'abord une mishima ensuite par
ordre chronologique ou par ordre de
préséance
mais enfin je pense que dieu n'est pas
une mine un peu de fantaisie donnant
donc pas vous commencez par mishima
mais c'est tout de même à vous que je
vais poser la première question jean
d'ormesson selon vous qui connaissez
bien le mari tueur sonar
qu'est ce qui l'a déterminé à écrire un
livre sur ce grand écrivain japonais
mishima
je ne voulais pas répondre à la place de
marguerite yourcenar et se voir si vous
la connaissez bien
il ya d'abord il ya d'abord quelque
chose de fantastique dans dans la vie
mishima c'est sa mort alors évidemment
surtout pour quelqu'un qui comme
marguerite yourcenar est comme moi je
crois pensons que ce qui compte dans un
écrivain c'est d'abord son oeuvre et non
pas sa vie il ya là un exemple de
quelqu'un ou la mort prend une telle
importance qu on ne peut pas parler de
son oeuvre
sans parler de sa mort c'est à dire de
sa vie ça ça me paraît quelque chose qui
est extraordinairement fort on ne pourra
évidemment plus jamais évoquer les
livres de mishima
sans parler de cette fin terrible est-ce
que la réponse vous satisfait et je
dirais que la mort de mishima est une de
ses oeuvres est la plus soigneusement
préparé de ses heures autrement dit si
mich emma au lieu de de se donner la
mort et on verra tout à l'heure comme en
a 45 ans était mort d'un cancer ou mort
d'un accident de voiture vous n'auriez
problement pas écrit un livre sur lui
peut-être j'aurais apprécié certaines
ses livres être leur ai vu en lui un
exemple très intéressant d'un japonais
européaniser et retournant un peu à la
fois à la pensée ancestrale mais enfin
j'aurais sans doute intéressés je ne le
suis alors parlons tout de suite de la
mort de mishima qui est sa dernière
oeuvre
c'est une mort qui laquelle il pense
depuis plusieurs années au moins six ans
oui on peut suivre dans les livres
écrits
dans les six dernières années cette
obsession de sept morts dont on peut
dire qu'il fait plusieurs répétitions
il ya aussi un film ça il joue même
cette mort dans un glissement de marc
câble alors il se donne la mort le 25
novembre 1970
mais d'abord ce jour-là une termine une
oeuvre
c'est cela l'enjeu ce que je sais que je
vais présenter dans mon livre comme
l'ange pourri et qui paraîtra le titre
dans la traduction par gallimard sera
l'ange en décomposition le livre est
paru
alors il a mis donc le point final on ne
sait pas s'il a écrit la dernière phrase
ou s'il a vraiment corriger amplement
corriger quelques virgules
en tout cas il avait promis à son
éditeur le manuscrit définitif c'est
cela et il l'a envoyé à l'éditeur vers 9
heures du matin le jour de sa mort mais
que fait-il après écrit-il après il
s'habille soigneusement dans l'uniforme
de cette espèce de société deux à la
fois société de gymnastique société
secrète requis pour lui représentait une
espèce de protestation contre les
traités qui limitait les armements du
japon est en fait qu il limiter la
liberté japonaise et qui comportait tout
au plus 100 tonnes
c'était beaucoup plus symbolique
symbolique que pratique et ne voudrait
pas étendre davantage disait-il
cette société il s'habille donc de cet
uniforme rejoint quelques amis qui
appartenaient au même groupe et alors
par des moyens en somme terroristes qui
nous gêne un peu maintenant surtout que
depuis dix ans nous avons vu de nombreux
exemples de terrorisme plus grave encore
seront chez le commandant de la place de
tokyo en général en général pour lui
montrer
il prétendait rambur ans est visé pour
lui montrer un sabre du xviie siècle
qu'il possédait dont il était très fier
et pour faire admirer au général
magnifique silure du sabre et pendant
que general se pencher sur le sabre et
les saisies
à part les trois acolytes de mishima on
ferme de l'intérieur les portes à clé et
le général et ligoté à son siège et on
lui demande de par téléphone d'ordonner
qu'on réunisse la troupe enfin les
troupes disponibles dans la cour pour
que mishima puisse le faire devant les
troupes sa protestation final on
parlemente pendant quelques temps on
finit par accepter cette demande de
crainte du pire et on réunit les trous
qui bien entendu s'élevait à environ
seulement 800 ou 900 hommes qui se sont
réunis salle enthousiasme ne comprends
pas très bien pourquoi cette corvée
d'autre part prudemment les comment
dirais-je le bureau du général fait
prévenir je ne sais quel ministère et on
envoie un hélicoptère qui passe et
repasse au-dessus de la cour où doit
avoir lieu ce dernier discours de
protestation michel marquis était un
athlète très remarquable saute sur le
rebord du balcon comment sa protestation
japonais vous ne vous rendez pas compte
que notre pays enfin perdu son honneur
et qui les tempes de sortir de ce
marasme et de rentrer dans des principes
enfin qu un peu plus noble et un peu
moins soumises aux directives de la
nation étrangère enfin je cible tout ça
de mémoire il a à peu près ce qu'il a
voulu dire
et naturellement personne de l'entente
il rit même oui je suis le manque de lui
tout le monde se moque de nuit ou sait
pas trop ce qui se passe l'hélicoptère
bourdonne au dessus de la cour mishima
redescendu au bord de la balustrade
rentrer dans le bureau du général fermée
à clé combien indiqué s'assied à un
mètre du général et accomplit son cpu
c'est plus qu le mot aux nobles le mot
chinois qui signifie la mise à mort par
éventuellement est en fête
quoique ce serait forte anciens mais
dans beaucoup de cas la personne qu'ils
accomplissaient généralement par
protestation ou comme une forme de
suicide imposé par l'empereur où
l'autorité de ces de ces années-là
n'arrivait pas à se tuer il n'arrivait
qu'à souffrir beaucoup et ça a privé une
blessure très douloureuse mais il est
être entendu dans nombre de cas qu'il
serait qu'il recevrait le coup de grâce
d'un acolyte et c'est ce qu'on avait à
ranger dans le cadre des films à un de
ses lieutenants devait lui trancher la
tête immédiatement selon l'usagé
il s'appelle morita c'est plus qu'un
lieutenant il s'appelait morita c'est
aussi le dernier la dette la grèce a
n'ayant pas entrer dans ce groupe est un
ami intime
certains m'ont même dit que c'était son
amant ça non seulement ils se lancent ah
bon alors donc d'ailleurs on voit un
document où l'on voit les deux têtes
tranchées parce qu'ensuite lamy qui lui
a coupé la tête se fait aussi couper la
tête par un autre et on voit que
l'extrême gauche les les deux têtes
les deux têtes qui venait de couper
évidemment les ce moment là les midis et
interviennent est comme gelée indique
aidé à lire dans le livre il ya là c'est
toute cette chose ce jour si émouvante
dans patriotisme dans le film de mishima
le cpq se dérouler avec une dignité et
une perfection imperturbable dans la
réalité ça ne s'est pas passé tout à
fait de la même façon le l'acolyte enfin
morita a été saisie de deux douleurs et
d'angoissant voyant mourir son chef
ça m'en a beaucoup tremblé il n'a pas
réussi à décapiter il a fallu que ce
soit quelqu'un d'autre qui me fasse et
lui même a été immédiatement
immédiatement reçu le coup de grâce
aussi d'un second acolytes
voilà donc il ya eu un désarroi qui est
dans quillan l'art au contraire ne s'est
pas produit et se produit pas dans le
film
jean d'ormesson commandes quelle
explication de cette mort parce qu'il
faut bien dire que mishima et un
écrivain très connu qui a obtenu
beaucoup de succès qui est riche et qui
a le carton recueilli tous les honneurs
et puis le tout d'un coup à 45 ans il
supprime justement ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir c est ce que mishima qui
représente une
tendance d'extrême droite le spa de
l'élite japonais peut-être un peu
différent de notre extrême mais est ce
que c'est pour ses opinions politiques
qui s'est suicidé ou est ce que il était
travaillée l'un besoin de suicide et
qu'il a choisi ce cheval de ce cheval
suicidaire comme il en aurait choisi un
autre est ce que vous croyez que c'est
vraiment pour les motifs politiques qui
s'est suicidé ou qu'il était décidé à se
suicider et qu'il a choisi la voie
politique je crois qu'on ne peut jamais
répondre simplement une question de ses
ordres que les motifs d'un être humain
son centre croise toujours et plus
l'homme est intelligent plus l'homme et
raffinée plus il y a un nombre
considérable de motifs quelquefois même
contradictoires certainement oui film a
été hanté toute sa vie par l'idée de la
mort en tant que japonais il a toujours
était plat d'une profonde admiration
pour les road sera ce qui s'était
suicidé de cette manière là
d'autre part il a raconté lui même très
franchement que dans sa jeunesse par
exemple lorsque jeunes étudiants et les
regrets dans les rues de tokyo incendié
par les bombes
il n'était pas particulièrement sensible
à la défaite du japon à se préoccuper de
sa propre carrière de la mort de sa
jeune soeur qui venait de mourir d'une
fièvre typhoïde et c est que la
politique ne l'intéressait pas à ce
moment là beaucoup
il avait même été enchantés d'avoir
refusé à l'armée comme conscrits parce
que il souffrait légèrement d'une
tuberculose d'un commencement du berck
culoz d'autre part 20 ans était passé
ses souvenirs s'était mise en place il
avait été hanté par la l'image de la
défaite japonaise et surtout par l'image
du trop facile réalignement des affaires
sont les affaires qui avaient
immédiatement suivi on s'en aperçoit
très bien dans son oeuvre
il avait décrit d'une façon hallucinante
toxo tokyo incendiés dans laquelle il
est vrai sans trop pire réfléchir
lorsqu'il avait 20 ans et 20 ans plus
tard il avait montré une façon admirable
je trouve dans un de ses romans ses
espaces complètement désert
hiro reconnaissable et une vieille femme
assise sur un banc tâchant de retrouver
l'endroit où elle avait vécu donc entre
temps une comment dirais-je une
évolution s'était fait en lui
de plus il était extrêmement sensible à
ce monde du succès à ce monde eu la vie
facile de la dolce vita guitare qui
l'avait d'ailleurs à laquelle il avait
participé lui-même mais il s'en était
sans doute lassé ou en tout cas ils
envoyaient les mauvais aspects et dans
plusieurs poèmes qui précède peu sa mort
il se plaint que la vie ait perdu son
goût et son sel est alors en fait de
toutes ces deux désespoir de ces
assurances faites à ses amis que le
japon ne s'en sortirait pas qu'il
entrait dans une période descendante est
sorti évidemment peu un peu à peu un un
peu à la fois cette décision de mourir
alors là dessus on a raconté toutes
sortes de choses on a parlé
d'exhibitionnisme
on a parlé du fait qu'ils n'avaient pas
eu prix nobel l'année précédente
oui c'est un peu excessif comme réaction
mais il ya quand même d'une autre une
autre version plus haut à votre avis
là-dessus jean d'ormesson
beaucoup ont dit aussi que et là c'est
la lecture de la mer de fertilité qui
nous encourage un petit cul et asseyons
à savoir que à 45 ans il a eu peur de la
vieillesse il a eu peur de l'échec final
il a et qu'il a voulu contre
contrairement à ce que ne fait pas honda
c'est le héros de l'amer 6 fertilité il
a voulu mourir enfin en pleine
possession de ses moyens il a toujours
cru que c'était là la mort enfin la plus
souhaitable voilà plutôt que d'attendre
une sorte de dégradation physique
intellectuelle non je ne crois pas qu'il
ait monté cet immense et compliqué mise
en scène de suicide avec protestation
aux troupes banderole déployée etc
précédé par pas mal d'action politique
comme par exemple son grand débat avec
les étudiants communistes de tokyo dans
lequel il reconnaissait que jusqu'à un
certain point il leur appartenait tout
en étant leur adversaire puisque tous
deux avaient le goût de l'action pousser
jusqu'à l'extrême limite mais je ne
crois pas qu'il aurait fait tout ça
simplement pour ceux pour s'offrir une
porte de sortie
si on peut rêver quand même qu est ce
qui se serait passé si les troupes au
lieu de riz avec se moquer l'avait suivi
parce qu'ils en auraient été heureux
ou est-ce qu'il va narrer était
désespérée corps effet napoléon s'il
vient du vainqueur le faire leurs biens
sont non seulement il a faim il probable
que mishima ce serait quand même suicidé
même dans le succès vous le croyez
peut-être un peu plus tard moment car on
se rend bien compte que rien ne pouvait
mener loin à ce moment là que cette
protestation même si elle avait été
suivie d'un certain sucré n'aurait tout
de même pas changer les choses est
particulièrement changer les traités
contre lesquels mes schémas protège mais
en fait c'est un homme tout à fait
curieux et vous parlez très souvent des
des photographies il s'est souvent
laissé photographier et dans des usa
dans des situations un petit peu
extravagante par exemple et vous en
parlez dans votre livre de cette
photographie où il est représenté en
saint-sébastien perd ses deux flèches
tout à fait extravagance a quand même
non non parce qu'après il y avait en mai
cimade l'acteur il avait très souvent
joué sur la chaîne il avait d'abord joué
et admirablement le principal rôle dans
le film patriotisme il a lancé sébastien
il avait ayant un goût passionné pour
racine qui ne peut que nous toucher il
avait joué un rôle de comparse dans
britannicus traduit en japonais par lui
ou pas comme une traduction révisée par
ses soins il avait joué dans certaines
pièces de kabuki il y avait donc en lui
de l'acteur le point de se détériorer en
acteur d'autre part est là qu il a
publié tout ou plutôt on a publié juste
après sa mort tout un album qu'il
représente mourant de diverses mort plus
ou moins symbolique et tout fait dans la
boue écrasé par un camion on peut voir
assez facilement certain symbolisme qui
crève les yeux ans à sébastien
se suicidant en commettant c'est plus
comme il l'a fait lui-même et il y a là
une certainement une obsession de la
mort or pour nos contemporains les
options de la mort paraît toujours un
peu malsaine un peu insensé et pourquoi
donc penser à tout ça mais là nous
sommes nouveaux
nous sommes des novateurs comparer non
seulement au japon et à l'extrême orient
au contraire on a toujours beaucoup
penser à la mort mais même à nos propre
aux ancêtres nos arrière-grands-parents
penser à leurs fins dernières il pensait
même chaque soir dans leur examen de
conscience est considéré en fait se
demander souvent quand même le faisait
madame de sévigné
comment pourrais-je serait tuée dans un
accident de voiture
mon rêve d'une fièvre de stress est ce
que ce sera subitement ou lentement
enfin et c est à ce genre de réflexion
est excessivement courant dans la
littérature chrétienne
jusqu'au xviiie siècle jean d'ormesson
vous avez lu les romans nishima qu'est
ce que ferait quand même parlé aussi un
peu de passes moment de sa vie mais
aussi par les deux de ses romans
pourquoi selon vous c'est un grand
écrivain il faut dire d'abord qu'il a
publié beaucoup d'heures qu'il a publié
près d'une quarantaine mais qu'elle a
beaucoup qui sont des ouvrages un petit
peu je dirais de commerciaux littérature
et les cadeaux alimentaire mais enfin il
a écrit une dizaine qui sont des grands
lignes je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que ce
fanatique japonais oui cet ardent
défenseur du retour à la puissance de
l'emprunt a été très influencé par
l'occident et étaient au moins très
curieux l'occident très influencé par la
france c'est pas la france il parle de
crise de dracy lui parle de racine
passionnément il parle de balsa ce qu il
avait aussi une culture anglaise assez
importante
pas du tout américaine c'est assez
frappant parce que le japon depuis et
même à l'époque où il souffrait enfin
des changements qui s'était produit dans
la civilisation japonaise était et est
encore fortement américanisé mishima
n'était pas américanisé il était
anglicisé offensive il ya quelque chose
d'assez frappant c'est que ces
influences mais là des choses qui elles
nous sont difficiles
compréhensible par exemple le thème de
la transmigration des âmes qui joua un
grand rôle dans le dense à d'être à
logis dans la mer de la fortune est à la
mer la fertilité dans le don le dernier
volume nous avons quatre lieux qui sont
parus qui viennent de paraître
alors là un lecteur européen est
peut-être un peu décontenancé oui par le
rôle de ceux de ce ce passage des armes
il est sans doute mais pas peut-être pas
plus qu'un lecteur orientale serait
comment dirais je
tout d'un coup surpris par la notion du
jugement dernier enfin il s'agit là de
dogme on sait ce taux qui de part et
d'autre sont acceptées même par les gens
qui n'y croient pas comme enfin un
concept qu'on accepte facilement
maintenant il faut bien dire y'a une
chose assez curieuse dans la question de
la religion des religions si on peut
dire car après tout le japon à deux
religions de mishima il ya le shintô qui
est le culte impérial que des ancêtres
le cumul des lieux sacrés de la terre
mishima a toujours eu un certain intérêt
et même un très grand intérêt pour ce
poste et jusqu'à un certain point
certainement il ya certaines ses plus
belles descriptions s'y rapportent
comme par exemple celle des suicides des
samouraïs qui assiste à des rites à des
cérémonies femto avant de se tuer au
moment où commencent et
l'européanisation du japon vers le début
du siècle
d'autre part le bouddhisme qui est aussi
une part profond de l'âme japonaise
semble avoir beaucoup moins intéressé et
on a par moment l'impression qu'il s'est
informée du bouddhisme presque à coups
de manuels les à coups de dictionnaires
pour revenir un peu à ses pensées
d'autrefois qui pour lui était une
pensée d'autrefois moi je la crois
encore très vivante mais un peu comme
agen du français qui n'auraient pas été
élevé dans le catholicisme qui tout d'un
coup s'y intéresseraient vous se
mettrait tout d'un coup à lire les
théologies gars et dont le
dans le temps la tétralogie de la
fertilité et il est certain que cela sa
présentation de la transmigration est
plus populaire que sa vente
c'est à dire qu'une souche de légendes
populaires des superstitions populaires
comme par exemple que très souvent des
personnes se réincarnant successivement
meurent plus ou moins au même âge ce qui
n'est défendue par aucune théorie et
théologique que je sache et car la
théologie bouder quand il s'agit de la
transmigration et si extraordinairement
compliquée s'ils savent qu'il est
excessivement difficile à définir mais
en un mot on peut se référer à une
grande phrase qui est d'origine hindoue
east le seigneur seul transmig c'est à
dire les éléments les plus élevés de
notre personnalité ne meurt pas ce qui
ne veut pas du tout dire que notre
individualité demeure et surtout pour
les bouddhistes ne crois pas du tout à
l'individualité pour qu'il n'existe pas
pour qui l'homme comme pour marcel
proust mais que le lieu d'un passage
d'émotions et de sensations qui sans
cesse se détruisent l'une l'autre
on ne voit pas très bien ce qu'ils
transmig regret donc il ya là un jeu et
j'ai mishima entre la position
théologique véritable et la position
populaire fait ce qu on dit couramment
dans la conversation
mais dans la mer de fertilité il ya
plusieurs personnages qui ont trois
grains de beauté toujours la même c'est
une nouvelle super c'est que ça veut
dire que ce sont des élus on se fabrique
ce sont des gens qui suivent en quelque
sorte la même ligne est grande migration
on retrouve des thèmes de ce genre par
exemple la call you run qu'en racontant
des légendes japonaises de la fin du 19e
siècle et ceux qui ne se fume pas moins
du point de vue purement esthétique du
point de vue romanesque c'est que ça a
permis à mishima d'offrir du japon de
boillon de 1912 1932 1954 et 1970
quatre images qui au lieu d'être comme
dans la plupart de nos romans européen
et quand il s'agit d'écrire une série de
génération on prend le père l'arrière
grand-père le père
le grand-père le père et le fils et on
reste à l'intérieur d'une famille comme
par exemple thomas semaine dans les
buddenbrook ou kong alberti que nous
lisons match en moins ou comme tout le
monde ou j'oserais même dire comme moi
d'un verre chief d'une un souvenir pieux
qui ne sont pas là lire des romans
tandis que dans le cas de mishima là
l'idée de représenter des personnages
transmis grand lui a permis de prendre
chaque fois des personnels de type
différent si tu es des niveaux sociaux
ou dans des milieux différents et ça ça
sans mérite
mais est ce que vous considérez
j'entends me sens que la merde fertilité
c'est le testament
évidemment on se dit puisqu'il termine
ce livre le jour même où il se donne la
mort blis son testament mais ce que
vraiment si son testament pour vous ça
ces questions vraiment difficiles vous
savez que je crois qu'il est ce au
moment de mourir je crois qu'il écrit
une phrase oui à bonaparte qui est
quitte une phrase admirable d'ailleurs
et qui est qui est une phrase sur la vie
autant que sont la mort je ne me
rappelle pas exactement les termes de
leur race et les îles à la vire
la vie humaine est brève mais je
voudrais vivre toujours vouvoyé et et
c'est ça c'est très curieux aussi
comment l'interprétez-vous sage a trouvé
c'est simple je comprends il ya ce grand
amour de la vie j'ai presque tous les
créateurs je crois que tous les grands
créateurs au malaise comme par exemple
balzac ont passionnément aimée l'avait
seulement dans quelles conditions
mishima souffre et évidemment peut-être
de certaines préoccupations et trouble
personnel que nous ne connaissons pas
vous pouvez pas proposer qu'on n'a pas à
être jugé
je me sens pas évoqué d'autre part il
souffrait certainement cruellement de la
situation de son pays
et évidemment la vie humaine est brève
et je voudrais vivre toujours à
condition que les conditions soient
tolérable et que ne soit pas non plus si
on peut dire d honneur mais vous dites
vous même qu'il a écrit un livre heureux
et vous dites vous même que c'est un
sorte de chefs-d'oeuvre c'est le tumulte
des flots c'est ça il était d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus jeunes oui il avec ella
jeudi écrit sable trentaine d'années
manière d
au numéro 25 35 il devait avoir environ
28 ans attends je suis pas sûr mais
c'est un livre d'amour et un ravissant
une ravissante histoire d'amour qui
ressemble à daphnis et chloé et qui à
mon avis même a le mérite d'être
infiniment plus réaliste se passe on
dans un milieu très pauvre permis des
pêcheurs d'une petite île et évoquant un
amour sans complexe mais avec toutes les
difficultés de la pauvreté de la
séparation des deux amoureux ça beaucoup
de grâce et il ya quelques scènes
inoubliables qui commence déjà
d'ailleurs l'obsession qui sera la
sienne de la différence entre une
société de consommation entre un monde
de luxe et le monde de la pauvreté qui
tout de même lui sous jacent sous
jacents et on verra mais de façon très
forte dans la dans la tétralogie ce
thème dans chevaux échappés où il à
aulus contre les commandes et rêvent les
grands trusts les grandes sociétés
affairistes et bien déjà dans un coin
d'un très court et très émouvant symbole
dans ce livre heureux dont je parle
il y à la scène 2000 qui sont des des
pêcheuses de perles en quelque sorte des
pêcheuses d'abalo n'est plus exactement
sorte de la mer glacée haletante et
caetera et se couche tout nu ce autour
d'un feu pour se réchauffer un tout
petit peu et à ce moment là parce le
colporteur venus de la ville apportant
des petits sacs en plastique qui coûte
très cher et les pauvres femmes qui
s'épuise et meurt à la tâche regardent
avec convoitise les petits sacs en
plastique qui coûte tout au plus qui
devrait coûter tout au plus un dollar
c'est un peu plus cher et qui est kim et
qui décide de les acheter enfin sont
prises par ce faux luxe qui leur est
offert du dehors
c'est tout chaud et c'est triste
faudrait dire un mot aussi d'un beau
livre qui le pavillon d'or tribaux vous
dites une manière de shadocks est un
très beau film manière du québécois le
pavillon d'or dans le pavillon d'heure
c'est l'histoire d'un
d'un avis qui ne met le feu son temps et
qui adore qui est qui et qui adore son
temple et qui met le feu
ce qui est quand même aussi une image de
la vie de mishima mais oui et c'est
aussi ce tri curieusement quelque chose
qu'on pourrait transposer en termes
occidentaux car c'était encore l'époque
où mishima écrivait des romans un peu un
peu comme le roman occident même tout à
fait comme le roman occidentaux et alors
ce jeune séminariste carré les
séminaristes bouddhiste qui à la fois
adore le temple
si les tees et d'un séminariste
catholique je dirais adore l'église dans
laquelle qui laquelle il a l'occasion
d'aller et venir tous les jours et qui
en même temps se trouve très irrité par
les enseignements qui lui semblent
routinier et un peu poussiéreux qu'on
lui donne on voit on va très bien un
écrivain même à bernanos
nous représentons un séminariste
catholique pris entre la halle à fouras
le mécontentement le découragement le
désespoir devant une religion qui lui
donne plus autant qu'il pourrait
l'espérer et son amour passionné pour
certaines structures certains souvenirs
du gond passé religieux qui elle
représente bien sûr je le désespoir et
la mort comme acte d'amour moi il ya une
chose que je tout à fait fascinant c'est
le suicide d'un autre écrivain japonais
c'est de l'écrivain kawabata qu il eut
obtenu le prix nobel de littérature qui
se suicident à raison à l'occidentale
alors qui suis un an c'est pas ce mâle
occidental depuis un an après mishima
il faut dire que il a été le maître de
mishima med mais lui est ensoleillée
alors il sait pas ce mot occidental je
dirais il se suicide comme les pauvres
gens c'est à dire il ouvre le gaz
simplement
alors je dirai ce que conduit à une à
bell donc alors que cet argument n'était
pas décisif mais barry bonds mais est ce
que je n'arrive pas les subit beaucaire
web attaque pourquoi ce sui team au gaz
est ce qu'il n'ya pas il ne donne pas
une leçon un an après la mort de michel
foucault pas du tout parce qu'il avait
il était resté jusqu'au bout la bbc mal
la photographie qu'il montre assistant à
l'enterrement est évidemment désolé et
extrêmement émouvante
et de plus il avait raconté par été
plusieurs fois avoir vu l'apparition de
mishima durant la dernière la dernière
année avant l'année qui sépare la mort
de mishima de sa propre mort je crois
qu'il s'est suicidé
deux nouveaux ne connaissons pas les
raisons secrètes comme mishima comme
cave à bata n'était pas un écrivain
d'éthique politique pour autant que je
sache ne savons pas non plus quelle est
son point de vue vis-à-vis des affaires
du monde
il s'est suicidé parce qu'ils en avaient
assez et tout simplement qu'ils vont
envisager aussi et était beaucoup plus
âgée et comme comme son art qui est un
tout en nuances tout en finesse je crois
qu'ils émanent le plus discrètement
possible mais kawabata fait ce que honda
ne fait pas dans la mer de fertilité
c'est d'ailleurs vous voudriez commandes
à ces suicides qui il a le regret à
certains moments vers la fin il eut
comme une voie qu'il est en pleine
déliquescence à la famille tuche il a le
regret un peu je ne suis pas tout à fait
raison je crois que mona mashima veut
nous montrer un monde à passant par la
déliquescence la vieillesse la sénilité
les est certainement certaines certains
drames de sa vie privée comme un gamin
certains scandales de moeurs qui se
produit et devant tout au mieux toutes
ces misères honda tout d'un tout de même
avance un peu à la fois
il commence à réfléchir un peu plus
profondément à ça dit il comme et
certaines erreurs graves comme par
exemple ils adoptent quelqu'un qui ne
méritait pas d'être adopté et on souffre
beaucoup
mais finalement il se décider à l'heure
c'est là tout de même un des moments
héroïques de livres il se décide à
remonter la colline du monastère où se
trouve la jeune femme qui avait été
l'ami et l'amante de son ami de son
camarade fallait d'autrefois et il
n'avait de la pure vie depuis cinquante
mais il se dit que peut-être enfin à moi
mourir ces deux personnes âgées pourront
ensemble discuter du sens de la vie et
de leurs amis d'autrefois et il te
retrouves la baisse enfoncé comme
pourrait de nouveau être une abaisse de
chez nous dans la prière dans la
méditation et refusant de reparler de ce
qui a été samedi passionnel et sa vie
social d'autrefois et lui honda
péniblement ayant fait ce chemin pour
arriver jusqu'à elle
à un moment tout de même presque
d'affolement midi mais enfin si tout ça
ne compte pas c'est rien de tout ça n'a
vraiment existé à leur mois honda ou en
suis-je
est-ce que vous existez et la baisse
mais dit c'est à chacun nous d'en
décider selon son coeur monsieur honda
et à ce moment là elle le prend dans un
jardin petit jardin du monastère effet
très beau c'est un beau jour d'été et on
pourrait dire parce que pour la première
fois de sa vie honda qui est un homme c
poses haïk assez quelconque s'aperçoit
que le ciel était bleu et que c'est tout
de même très beau c'est à dire qu'il est
arrivé à une sorte d'élan d'idéalisme
avant de mourir
ça vaut peut-être la peine d'aller
jusqu'aux gâtisme pour en arriver là
bon encore un dernier mot sur le temple
de l'aube en face au tout la mère de
fertilité qui est traduit de l'anglais
est à noter par tanguy qui n'est plus
très bien mais alors est-ce qu'on peut
ne pas regretter que finalement la
traduction ne se fasse pas directement
du japonais qu'elle soit obligée de
passer par par l'anglais dans leur
maison vous vous qui êtes à l'unesco là
c'est un problème évidemment comment ne
le regretterai ton pas comment ne le
regretterai ton pas le principe de la
double traduction est un principe je me
rappelle que taiwan en parlait souvent
le principe de la double traduction est
un principe à peine admissible un peu
mais c'est très dangereux
vous imaginez les glissements qui se
font et magie magie dans tornos
d'ormesson traduit en anglais puis re
traduit en japonais
d'accord
bon bah ça doit peut-être d'avoir des
glissements quand même le sens dans tout
ça non mais écoutez on peut prendre
l'exemple du saf je parle sous votre
contrôle madame le dernier titre lange
en décomposition le dernier le quatrième
de la mer de fer trième de la mer de
fertilité lange en décomposition 7
c'est déjà beaucoup plus fort c'est déjà
plus fort et en japonais c'est une
formule qui se réfère à toute une
mythologie des anges qui qui ne sont pas
tout à fait immortel et qui décline et
il ya il ya cette plaie qui se forme sur
eux ils auront leurs fleurs ce phare
fleur se fane français dans leur
ensemble bien que l'ange en
décomposition c'est une formule un peu
stéréotypé qui veut dire il n'y a pas de
bonnes choses qui ne finissent même les
plus belles rosselini spar fans et alors
vous voyez c'est quelque chose qui à
l'oreille japonaise sonne de façon
beaucoup plus familière que l'ange en
décomposition viande pourrie marie
thurso nas ou penser que dieu est un bon
sujet de roman parce que là on abandonne
l'aca cette petite créature ok mishima
paie assez pour venir maintenant a dû
revenir à dieu et aux créatures ces
quelques vieux va poser les vieux qui
sont surtout je crois
chateaubriand et madame récamier voilà
bon alors changeons de sujet et pensons
à dieu voilà c'est bien je ne sais pas
du tout si dieu est un bon sujet droit
mais je crois que dieu est présent dans
tous les romans puisque après tout on
peut dire que c'est dieu ou bien qui
ordonne le monde bien qu'il rêve ou que
nous pouvons nous référer à lui en fait
à tout ce qui nous arrive
[Musique]